Speaker 1: Let's go to Jeff from Pennsylvania.
Jeff, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, first time caller.
This is awesome.
Beyond.
Thanks for picking me.
Thank you.
I was wondering with all the talk about polling
that we always hear.
This might be a dumb question, but where do
people get polled to collect this info?
Speaker 1: You look at the methodology of
each poll and it will tell you that and it
will tell you the combination.
You know, typically it's landlines, cell phones.
Sometimes there are online elements to the
poll, but there's not one answer to that,
and it's in the methodology.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Because I was thinking, you know, if people
are getting reached out to on landlines and
phones and I don't know, most people at this
point don't pick up four calls that are, you
know, suspicious or they don't recognize.
Then I don't know.
How much stock can you put into polling in
that case?
Speaker 1: Yeah, your skepticism isn't new.
This is an issue that people have talked about
for a while, which is especially if it's only
landlines.
Most polls are not only landlines at this
point in time, I think the bigger and more
accurate concern around polling is only certain
people are even going to entertain a call
from pollsters.
I mean, listen, I'm I'm so busy, for example,
I don't really talk on the phone.
I don't even use my I barely use my phone.
I have periods of time where 4 hours I'm just
away from my phone.
I rarely pick it up.
I don't often I don't even listen to voicemails.
I'm basically like conducting business via
email for most of the things that I have going
on.
So it's true that there are only some people
who are even willing to get on the phone with
a pollster.
The way pollsters deal with that is they adjust
their sample to account for that.
But it's a fair question to say to what degree
can they really accurately and fairly adjust
the sample?
I think it's fair.
Polling has, by and large, still been pretty
accurate in most cases over the last four
years, although we certainly saw some specific
instances in which it was not.
So all good questions and important things
to ask.
Speaker 2: All right.
Well, that's what I had for today.
Speaker 1: Thanks so much very much.
Appreciate the call.
Let's see.
Let's go to Elias from Texas.
Elias, welcome.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
Thanks for calling on me.
How could a 5050 Senate differ from a 51 to
49 Senate?
Will Biden be able to get more done with a
simple majority?
Speaker 1: I think that he will not get more
done, but it will become irrelevant whether
both mansion and cinema want to go with what
Democrats are trying to do.
I've got a couple of clips about this.
Basically the gist of it is when it's 5050,
you need all 50 Democrats in order to enable
Kamala Harris to break the tie.
If it's 5149, if Manchin doesn't want to go
with it, it doesn't matter anymore.
Or if Sinema doesn't want to go with it, it
doesn't matter anymore.
You still get to 5050 and Carmel is the tiebreaker.
Obviously, if both Manchin and Senate are
resisting, that's a different story.
But it just gives you breathing room.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
And I was just curious about what your efforts
are in Georgia if you went down there to go
help out with Warnock?
Personally, I'm helping with tax banking tomorrow.
So.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I am not going to be able
to make it down to Georgia, but we are going
to be in these last few days pushing hard,
making sure everybody knows about early voting.
We're going to do some, you know, uniting
around phone and text banking events.
And we're we're pushing as hard as we can
there.
So appreciate the questions.
And let's hope that's hope that Walker is
defeated there.
Speaker 2: Great.
Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: We're looking for massive dumps
of votes for Warnock.
All right, my friend.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Alice is gone there.
Very good.
All right, let's go to bars.
From the Netherlands.
Bars.
Welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hello.
Hello.
I had a question because I was somewhat furious
with a politician in my own country.
Mm hmm.
A politician of my own party, let's say.
And I got an email for.
In which he explained that.
Currently in our country are our judges have
the possibility to prohibit organizations
if they're dangerous to the country.
But that law excludes.
Both political parties from being outlawed.
He said that he would like to see that changed.
And for me, that was like it.
It made something losing me.
Like I got really mad over that.
And.
Well, because I think that's like the opposite
of democracy, even if like even if democratically
is decided.
You want to end democracy.
I think that's the purest form of democracy.
And even though that's weird.
Speaker 1: Boss, I'm sorry.
I don't know that I'm totally understanding
what you're saying.
I'm I certainly am not following politics
in Netherlands as closely as maybe I would
have to to to answer this question.
Did you have a question for me today?
Speaker 2: Mm.
Mhm.
No I'm not really dumb, I guess.
No.
Speaker 1: Boss.
Listen, I appreciate the call.
I just am not as I'm not well versed enough
in Dutch politics and I'm not sure it sounds
like you don't really have a question.
So let me look into what you're mentioning,
okay.
Thank you.
All right.
There is boss from the Netherlands with a
very, very powerful declaration.
Let's go to Nate from Rhode Island.
Nate, welcome.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, how you doing?
Doing well.
So I have a question.
So with regards to the calls in the discord,
let me make a suggestion for future calls,
please.
So there's something called stage channels
that's a new feature and basically is just
for you.
It sounds like you have you the.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we're familiar with it, Nate.
Thank you.
We've looked into it and it was not obvious
from what we had that the moderators determined
that it really was going to be an improvement
in there.
It raised a couple of new issues, but we will
look into it again.
We're familiar with stages.
Speaker 2: All right.
And then just one other thing.
So to add to what you were talking with Elise
earlier about with regards to the Senate.
So in addition, with 51 Senate seats, we have
subpoena powers to we can start our own investigations
and also makes it easier to fast track judges.
Speaker 1: Yes, absolutely.
When it comes to when it comes to judges in
particular.
Now, on subpoena, doesn't that depend on having
a majority in particular committees?
Correct me if I'm wrong.
Speaker 2: I mean, I'm not too sure about.
I just read up on it.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Because my understanding was and I could be
wrong, Nate, that the subpoenas tend to come
not from the Senate at large, but rather from
specific committees like the Judiciary.
And even with a 5050 majority, they would
still have the majority in the committees.
So that was my understanding.
But I could be wrong.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm not sure I'd have to
look into that.
Thank you for bringing that up.
I'll have to research that momentarily.
Speaker 1: All right.
All right, Nate, great to hear from you.
Appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much for taking my
call.
Speaker 1: Have a hope and then he is gone.
All right.
Thank you, everybody, for calling in.
We're going to go to a break.
We will take more calls next week.
And it's going to be a beautiful thing.